you've mentioned too that most actors
are not good business people how did you
hone your left brain side your logical
side is that coming from still working
on elevator it's not it's a work in
progress but I think I'm done good
because I'm still making movies and
still driving expensive cars so there
must be some good work done on the left
side too well do you think that that's
the reason many creative people fail and
move home so to speak is because I'm
known great filmmakers who didn't have a
moment to consider themselves moving
away from themselves and realize how
great they are they're stuck in that
room that loneliness that monotonous
sounding television music are lulled by
drugs or alcohol they didn't know the
limit and they kill themselves at the
peak of their performing abilities it's
happened too few in India too I feel
very bad sad is that because they let
themselves go to now that because they
have not they then either they believe
the press too much of what's written
about them and truly believe that that's
what they are or they take criticism to
the very extreme and think that they are
finished it's like Chaplin sitting at
gold rush for two weeks saying that I'm
dried up I can't do anymore I'm finished
but there was a fantastic crew sitting
around him pampering him there's a lot
of money being wasted there wasn't a
hard producer tracking the web but it
got him through and he went on for a few
more years doing what he had to do
that's very important for an actor
somebody has to tell it can't be the
agent it can't be the producer it has to
be him to look into the mirror and feel
happy about
what he has achieved and how much more
he can do by living actress Dee Wallace
said if you believe the good then you
have to believe the bad oh yes but you
believe but don't keel over to the wrong
side but whichever side it is that you
Annie keel over then you go go down and
that's I I've had Norman's many moments
of indecision confusion and suddenly I
realized that there's so many things
that I didn't train well for and then
then you sort of set goals that you can
achieve and then you realize that's the
only way to live a life because if you
have a bicycle you want a motorcycle we
have a motorcycle you on a car have a
car you want an airplane to fly and then
you're on and probably a fleet of
airplanes there it could become a owner
of airway I mean there's no end to it
but there's someplace you'll have to
settle and see that you don't get into
the peter principle of everybody reaches
their level of incompetency so you must
stop just before them is it also about
managing expectations your own other
peoples yes yes I mean it's it's
complicated it's very easy to advice
especially give me a case I'm a great
advice I don't know how to do it to
myself and I that supplies for everyone
and so so it's a bit of listening bit of
disagreeing bit of agreeing and bit of
coming to terms but what you really are
and understanding that this world is so
full of talent and you only one among
them it takes a long time to adjust to
that truth especially when you read good
press so but I'm the past there's nobody
around like me and then you have to sit
down ruminate and understand that many
have said this before its too many
you